(audience clapping)
(upbeat trumpet music)
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] We love you, Angela!
- I love you!
Regina, my dear, dear Regina.
My sister,
thank you for being here tonight
as a source of support
and encouragement and joy.
Working alongside you has been one
of the highlights of my career.
You are for me, and for so
many, a bright, bright light.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
It is because of the love
and support of my friends
and my family that I
stand here this evening.
I offer a lifetime and beyond of gratitude
to my sister, Danette,
my husband, Courtney,
and our beautiful children,
Bronwyn and Slater.
(audience clapping)
Whom I'm blessed to have
with me this evening.
Rest on your feet.
Look at 'em.
(audience clapping)
They have each in their own
way made space in our lives
to allow me the freedom
to be a sister, a mother,
a wife, and an actor.
I love you wholly and deeply.
To the women who shower
me with heavenly love,
my mother Betty and my aunt Golden,
both who loved and nurtured me
in spite of their concerns that I chose
to use my Yale degrees to pursue acting.
(audience laughing)
I say thank you.
Thank you for the gift of
allowing me to chase my dreams.
Thank you to my amazing team,
Darrell, Leslie, Steven,
Jeffrey, Bill, Anita,
Gilda, DeAndre, Jennifer, Randy,
as well as Bassett Vance
Productions, Lynette,
Lonnie, Eric, and Chelsea.
I sincerely appreciate
all that you do with me
and for me each day.
Thank you to every director,
casting director, producer, studio exec,
costume designer, hair and makeup team,
production design team,
as well as fellow cast members and crew
whom I've had the
pleasure to work alongside
while making magic.
Thank you.
Thank you to the Academy
and the Board of Governors
for this, this award.
I have considered acting my
calling and not just my career.
I do this work because
I find it meaningful
and I hope in some way
that it makes a difference
and has an impact.
To be recognized in this
way for what I love doing
is truly wonderful, and
I am beyond grateful.
You know, Lena Horne once said,
"It's so nice to get flowers
while you can yet still
smell the fragrance,"
and indeed it is.
(audience laughing)
You know,
I have had to let it sink in that
I am the second Black actress
to receive an honorary Oscar,
the first being my dear friend and mentor,
the late Cicely Tyson in 2018.
(audience clapping)
Having a chance to work with
and learn from Ms. Tyson is
one of the most memorable
and treasured experiences
of my career and life,
and I hope that she is
smiling from the heavens
that I'm able to join her in
this circle of recognition
Knowing that she was so impactful to me
as an actress and as a woman.
I thought long and hard about
what I'd say this evening.
This for me is not just another award,
it's a testament to my legacy.
This trophy represents my contributions
to this medium of film,
all that I've given of my mind, body,
and spirit as an actress
who is a Black woman.
So,
do I go the route of saying
a few words of gratitude for
what this moment means to me
or do I give voice to what I hope
this moment should mean for generations
of Black actresses to come?
As I look to the future,
I think that it would be of service
to face that which we all must contend
as we look toward tomorrow and beyond.
So, if you will open
your hearts and minds,
I'll just share my personal reflection.
And we're days away from
Martin Luther King Jr. holiday.
And something he once
said touched my spirit
in thinking about what I
would say this evening.
"We are not makers of history.
We are made by history."
To put what this moment means to me
in historical context,
my mind traveled back
to February 29th, 1940,
the 12th Annual Academy Award,
the ceremony when actor, singer,
songwriting Hadie McDaniel became
the first Black person
to ever win an Oscar.
(audience clapping)
Before she took the stage, the
actress, Fay Bainter, said,
"It is more than a plaque of gold."
- [Audience Member] Yes!
- "It opens the doors of this room.
It moves back the walls
and enables us to embrace
the whole of America,
an America that almost is
alone in the world today.
It recognizes and pays tribute
to those who have given their best,
regardless of creed, race, or color."
It was at this point that Ms. McDaniel
walked from the back of that
Coconut Grove restaurant,
passed the table where her fellow
"Gone with the Wind" castmates
and studio executives were seated,
that she historically tore down a barrier,
making it possible for Black actresses
to be seen and recognized
at the highest levels in our
industry for their contribution on film.
(audience clapping)
And it would be another 50 years
before another Black
woman would win an Oscar,
that extraordinary woman being
my dear sister friend, Whoopi,
and still more than a decade
before the next historical
milestone with Halle's win
as best actress,
which for more than two
decades remains the only.
We have Jennifer,
Monique, Octavia, Lupita,
Viola, Regina, and Ariana,
10 actresses who are makers
of history in our industry.
I call their names to
acknowledge every one
of them this evening for
being beacons of possibility
and hope for little Black
and Brown girls who aspire to one day
pursue the dream of becoming an actor.
When acting took hold of my heart,
there was not a clear path to
what success could look like
because there were so few,
so few Black actresses in prominent roles,
in television or film.
For me, those trailblazing actors,
like Ruby Dee, Diahann Carroll,
Cicely Tyson, and Rosalind Cash,
they were my North Star
and my guiding light,
proof that while the road may
not be without curves and bumps,
there was a way to fulfill what I
believed deep in my soul was my destiny.
So it was that standing on their strong,
spiritually fortified shoulders
that I often was sustained,
and I thank them for every sacrifice,
every doubt, every
disappointment, every rejection,
every triumph that I know
they experienced along the way
because had it not been
for their resilience,
continuing to fight through
their fears and the uncertainty
and their willingness as
they fought for every role,
I would not have had a representation of
what was possible for me.
But this honor isn't just for or about me.
What I hope this moment means is
that we are taking the necessary
steps toward a future in
which it is the norm, not the exception,
to see and embrace one
another's full humanity,
stories, and perspectives.
This must be our goal
and to always remember that
there is room for us all.
When we stand together, we win together.
(audience clapping)
To my fellow Black actresses...
- Yes!
- Fill your hearts with
courage and strength.
Because regardless of what
you may think or see or feel,
your contributions do matter.
Take comfort knowing
that your performances
have given hope, offered
a different perspective,
and for others, just pure
joy in a time of need.
Never allow fear, frustration,
or disappointment to get
in the way of the blessings
that are divinely and deservedly yours.
Remember who you are and who our ancestors
intended you to be, us to be.
I proudly share this honor with women
who stand up when they
are told to stand back,
who speak up when they are silenced,
who remain determined when they
are told they are defeated.
These women represent those
that I've had the honor
to portray as well as the
everyday woman who surround us
and inspire us to keep striving.
And to everyone in this room,
I say when it comes to what
we do, the decisions we make,
how we embrace one another,
how we should support
and lift up one another,
always remember that the
stakes are extremely high
because history depends on us.
Why?
Because we are the lens
through which future
generations will see themselves.
And my prayer is that we leave
this industry more enriched,
forward thinking, and
inclusive than we found it,
a future where there won't
be a first or an only,
or suspense around whether
history will be made
with a nomination or a win.
I have faith that one day, someday,
the celebration and recognition
will be solely on the
performance and the performer.
Because at the end of the day,
we all just want to have the opportunity
to do great, meaningful work.
(audience clapping)
Maya Angelou said very wisely,
"People will forget.
They will forget what you said.
People will forget.
They will forget what you did.
But people will never forget
the way you made them feel."
(audience clapping)
To all who have been
on this journey with me
and supported the films in which
I've had the privilege to play,
it is my profound honor
to have been able to make you
see and feel through my work.
Thank you for sharing this moment with me.
And still, I say, the best is yet to come.
(audience cheering)
(bright trumpet music)